este vídeo va a ser especial vamos a
hablar de industria militar y
normalmente los medios de comunicación
hablan poco y mal de estas cosas es un
tema muy jugoso para hacer artículos
clic bait en los que tocan la fibra
sensible del público y quedas como un
pacifista pero lo cierto es que los
ejércitos existen y es importante que
sepamos cómo funcionan así que como
siempre hacemos el visual político os
vamos a explicar qué es lo que ocurre en
este mundo para que luego vosotros os
forméis vuestra bendita opinión os
parece pues vamos con el vídeo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
eeuu tiene el mayor ejército del mundo
pero eso ya lo sabéis lo que seguro que
no sabéis son las proporciones para que
os hagáis una idea cada año la casa
blanca se gasta el defensa más que el
pib de toda polonia no sé 6 conscientes
de la burrada que acabo de decir
[Música]
pasando por un momento polonia es un
país europeo con casi 40 millones de
habitantes si sumamos todo lo que han
producido esos 40 millones de personas
en el año 2019 tenemos unos 560 mil
millones de dólares al año pues bien ese
mismo año eeuu se ha gastado casi 90 mil
millones más en ejército 649 mil
millones de dólares es que hasta asusta
decirlo por si todavía no os ha
estallado la cabeza pensad que china con
cuatro veces más población no llega ni a
la cuarta parte del gasto militar
estadounidense y os preguntaréis para
dónde se va tanto dinero
[Música]
y lo cierto es que defender un país es
un negocio caro muy caro por ejemplo tan
solo un tanque m1a1 abrams sale por 6
millones de dólares y esto entraría en
la categoría de juguetes baratos porque
si queréis un caza de combate de último
modelo como el mítico f-35 no lo
encontraréis por menos de 100 millones
de dólares y no creáis que hablamos
solamente de aviones y tanques
[Música]
pensar en un soldado un soldado
estadounidense de esos que están ahora
mismo en irak o en cualquier base
militar con su traje de camuflaje sus
gafas de visión nocturna y su fusil
cuánto dinero creéis que lleva encima
mil dólares dos mil dólares pues
agarrados a la silla diez mil dólares
habéis oído bien y diréis pero es esto
normal otros países se gastan cantidades
similares pues para que os hagáis una
idea un soldado equivalente del ejército
de marruecos lleva encima entre 500 y
1000 dólares como veis estamos hablando
de una de las industrias más grandes del
mundo una industria que emplea más de un
millón y medio de estadounidenses dentro
de este millón y medio está personal del
gobierno personal del ejército y por
supuesto empresas porque si amigos de
visual política la industria de defensa
estadounidense es un auténtico negocio
para muchos
a estas alturas la pregunta que todos
estaréis haciendo espero de verdad
estados unidos necesita tantísimo
ejército de verdad necesito un ejército
tan caro a fin de cuentas en este
momento eeuu no está en ninguna gran
guerra no sería mejor gastarse todo eso
en cosas constructivas como salud
educación o simplemente bajar los
impuestos a los sufridos ciudadanos
estadounidenses hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas y lo vamos a hacer de la
mano de nuestro experto en defensa
favorito
thiago rodríguez escribe regularmente en
la revista ejércitos punto o hereje hola
fonseca y un saludo a todos los
seguidores de visual político pues
efectivamente será discutible si es
bueno que eeuu gaste todo ese dinero en
defensa pero lo que está que los que
razones muy poderosas para que dicho
gasto se produzca pero incluso habría
que ir un paso más allá y plantearse si
eeuu está ganando dinero con todas estas
ventas o realmente no les resulta
estas gastos de inversión en defensa
pues lo dicho hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes antes vamos a
ver un poco de historia
[Música]
la doctrina mahan muchos pensaréis que
el 'tío sam' siempre ha estado loco por
las armas pero lo cierto es que en los
años 30 del siglo 20 el ejército de eeuu
era comparable al de un país tan pequeño
como portugal es más durante todo el
siglo 19 buena parte de la defensa de
este país estaba en manos privadas si
eran los propios empresarios quienes
contrataban a mercenarios para
defenderse de los ataques de los indios
pero la casa blanca estaba muy segura
sabiendo que nadie les podía atacar
estaban protegidos por dos grandes
océanos el atlántico y el pacífico es
decir que a diferencia de cualquier otro
país europeo
eeuu no necesitaba un ejército de tierra
y en este contexto es cuando aparece un
militar que se llamaba alfred taller
mahan y dice lo siguiente
los americanos deben empezar a mirar
hacia afuera la producción del país lo
requiere así alfred fire my hand capitán
del ejército estadounidense durante la
guerra de la secesión efectivamente la
llamada 'doctrina mahan de eeuu lo vine
a decir es que se ha de controlar se ha
de de ser una potencia marítima con el
control de determinados puntos clave
estrechos principalmente en los mares
para poder controlar el comercio y
protegerlo de ahí en parte el desarrollo
de grandes buques como por ejemplo los
portaaviones que permiten desplegar una
gran cantidad de poder aéreo gracias en
sus aviones en cualquier parte del mundo
sí es cierto por aquel entonces eeuu ya
tenía la marina más grande del mundo
pero a duras penas tenían un ejército de
tierra importante es más tras la segunda
guerra mundial eeuu estaba muy cómodo
porque había desarrollado algo único en
el mundo la bomba atómica todo esto era
más que suficiente para estar protegidos
de cualquier invasión básicamente
teniendo una bomba nuclear no hace falta
gastar más en armamento a fin
quien se va a atrever a invadir les sin
embargo las cosas estaban a punto de
cambiar
[Música]
sí
exacto no fue la segunda guerra mundial
sino la guerra de korea la que marcó un
antes y un después en la historia
militar estadounidense de repente la
casa blanca descubrió que los soviéticos
eran un auténtico rival de entrada
también habían descubierto a la bomba
atómica es más tenían armamento de
última generación y un ejército muy pero
que muy bien entrenado
las primeras derrotas en korea mandaban
un mensaje muy claro si pueden ganarte
en korea también pueden ganarte en
california y en ese momento es cuando el
por entonces presidente dwight
eisenhower enterró la doctrina maya y
desarrolló su propio manual de estilo
fue el momento de
[Música]
la estrategia de la disuasión tal vez
nos sorprenda pero durante la primera
guerra mundial todavía había ejércitos
montados a caballo y armados con lanzas
por aquellos años la guerra era una
cuestión de fuerza numérica y de
estrategia la tecnología
era algo menor todo esto cambio durante
la segunda guerra mundial
[Aplausos]
richard que por ejemplo en plena segunda
guerra mundial los alemanes serán
capaces de atacarlo andrés a decenas de
kilómetros mediante los cohetes v2 y que
en esa misma guerra se desarrolló el
proyecto manhattan que dio lugar a la
aparición de las primeras bombas
nucleares en dicho proyecto además los
científicos tuvieron un papel mucho más
predominante que los militares
naturalmente aparte de eso lo cierto es
que esto marca un cambio tecnológico un
cambio en el que la cantidad del número
de soldados deja de importar en favor
sobre todo de la tecnología y este
concepto del complejo militar-industrial
precisamente es concebido por el
presidente de eeuu dwight eisenhower
nos hemos visto obligados a crear una
industria permanente de armamento de
proporciones inmensas en alemán
a esto hay que añadirle 3 millones y
medio de hombres y mujeres que están
directamente relacionados con la defensa
cada año sólo en seguridad militar
gastamos más que todas las empresas de
eeuu este es el famoso discurso donde
aysén hauer se despide porque ya deja el
gobierno irónicamente en esta charla
eisenhower advertía a su sucesor de los
posibles riesgos de gastar demasiado en
ejército pero lo cierto es que ya era
demasiado tarde la carrera militar había
empezado y con ella una nueva doctrina
militar la estrategia de la disuasión
disuadir inducir o mover a alguien a
cambiar de opinión oa desistir de un
propósito y para que lo podéis entender
os voy a poner un ejemplo imaginaros un
cazo spitfire de la segunda guerra
mundial
en este caso el avión se puede rematar
con un martillo y unos clavos y personal
relativamente poco cualificado por lo
que se pueden fabricar muchos sin
embargo 20 años después tenemos el caza
f 86
indicada que supera la velocidad del
sonido y que requiere de una estructura
mucho más resistente de una serie de
reacciones que no puedes remachar que en
cualquier personal poco cualificado no
te puede producir
y qué significa todo esto pues que antes
era sencillo reconvertir la industria
civil en industria militar pero de
repente se había vuelto imposible en
otras palabras que si quieres disuadir a
tus enemigos de un posible ataque
necesita ser el líder tecnológico y para
ser el líder tecnológico no puedes parar
de invertir en nuevas tecnologías aunque
estemos en tiempos de pago os acordáis
de un vídeo que hicimos hace un año
donde hablábamos de la historia de
silicon valley pues si el germen de lo
que hoy en día es el centro mundial de
la innovación fue precisamente la
investigación militar pero esperad un
momento porque el concepto de disuasión
va mucho mucho más allá ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
[Música]
guerra eterna al principio del vídeo os
decíamos que hoy en día un soldado raso
lleva encima más de 10 mil dólares en
equipamiento de última generación y ya
me imagino lo que estaréis pensando
muchos envidia por supuesto a nadie nos
gusta la guerra a nadie nos gusta la
violencia pero a todos nos fascina la
tecnología os imagináis cómo sería
probar todos estos cacharros por un día
pues creedme no os habríais ni por dónde
empezar
[Música]
hoy en día cualquier soldado que está en
el frente tiene que saber cómo manejar
un dron cómo usar la tecnología de
camuflaje porque no os creéis que es
fácil o incluso mandar mensajes en clave
desde su equipo de radio os aseguro que
nada de esto se aprende en dos tardes
necesitaría jce años enteros de
entrenamiento y todo esto qué significa
para eeuu pues que han tenido que acabar
con el reclutamiento forzoso pensadlo
bien durante la segunda guerra mundial
todos los jóvenes estadounidenses
estaban obligados a enrolarse en el
ejército ahí se les daba una formación
de unos meses y se les mandaba al frente
durante la guerra de vietnam la casa
blanca optó por una solución algo más
moderada el reclutamiento limitado es
decir ya no eran todos los jóvenes sino
sólo aquellos que cumplían unas
características y si lo se podríamos
discutir durante horas sobre si el
reclutamiento forzoso es ético o no pero
hoy vamos a centrarnos en si es o no es
efectivo desde un punto de vista militar
y el problema con este sistema es que a
duras penas tenemos tiempo de entrenar a
los soldados básicamente empieza la
guerra reclutamos a miles de chicos y
como ya estamos en combate pues tampoco
podemos gastar mucho tiempo en educar
les después al terminar la guerra les
mandamos de nuevo para su casa y
esperamos que comiencen una vida civil y
de nuevo cuando empiece una nueva guerra
empiece otra vez el mismo proceso
todo esto es impensable hoy en día
porque porque eeuu necesita un ejército
profesional
[Música]
es decir gente que está en nómina y que
se entrena todos los días de nuevo da
igual si estamos en tiempos de guerra o
en tiempos de paz los soldados
profesionales no paran de entrenar
porque siempre tienen que estar
aprendiendo nuevas tecnologías pero la
pregunta la auténtica pregunta que nos
tenemos que hacer ahora es vale todo
esto está muy bien pero de verdad es
importante gastar tanto dinero en
tantísimo capital humano en tantísima
tecnología de verdad es de algún
resultado pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
[Música]
el ejército más grande del mundo 2 de
agosto del año 1990 eeuu entra en guerra
con el irak de sadam husein que había
invadido kuwait había empezado la
llamada guerra del golfo como sabéis
eeuu ganó esta guerra
[Aplausos]
pero de nuevo lo realmente impresionante
de esta guerra es el ratio de bajas se
calcula tirándolo a la baja que en torno
a 300 iraquíes habían caído por cada
soldado norteamericano es decir que
gracias a esa superioridad tecnológica y
esa ventaja tecnológica de más de 10
años sobre el ejército iraquí estados
unidos consigue aplastar consigue que
esta guerra ción pasión militar pero
como hace eeuu para tener un
equipamiento tan avanzado pues de nuevo
gracias a lo que llamamos el complejo
militar es decir la unión del gobierno
con empresas privadas vamos a poner un
ejemplo el f-35 en el año 1992 la casa
blanca sacó un concurso público para
renovar su flota de cazas de combate se
presentaron varias compañías finalmente
la ganadora fue el lockheed martin 28
años más tarde el proyecto del f-35 ha
terminado esto significa que a día de
hoy eeuu tiene el mejor avión de combate
del mundo ni rusia ni china pueden
competir con el f-35 y eso se nota en el
precio cada uno de estos juguetes cuesta
más de 100 millones de dólares y diréis
menos la ruina económica para
blanca verdad pues no tan rápido en 2018
salieron los primeros f-35 operativos y
ahora en 2019 y ya podemos encontrar
noticias como esta
no lo hagas se unió al proyecto del f-35
en noviembre de 2018 el ejército noruego
seleccionó el f-35 como reemplazo de su
flota de f-16 exacto la industria
militar estadounidense es también una de
sus principales exportaciones dicho de
otra forma eeuu se gasta todos los años
unos 650 mil millones de dólares en
defensa verdad casi todo ese dinero se
va en pagar nóminas de funcionario
mantenimiento de oficinas y compra de
armamento pues bien cuanto decís que
ingresan en exportaciones los eeuu de
américa pues algunas estimaciones llegan
a hablar de cuatrocientos mil millones
de dólares sólo en el año 2019 es decir
que buena parte de ese gasto vuelve al
país en forma de ventas y qué pasa con
el material que se queda obsoleto pues
en muchos casos cosas como esta
[Música]
eeuu aprueba la venta de aviones f-16 a
marruecos por valor de 4.800 millones de
dólares y ya se lo que estáis pensando a
ver fonseca pero no nos has dicho que
eeuu se gasta un pastizal para estar a
la cabeza en armamento pero si luego se
dedica a vender armas al resto del mundo
pues ya me dirás tú que el liderazgo
tecnológico no no pierden la ventaja
pues sí tenía razón y a la vez no veréis
el mercado de las armas está súper
regulado cada vez que uno empresa vende
material a otro país necesita la
aprobación del congreso donde esto
significa que eeuu sólo vende a sus
aliados pero también implica una enorme
arma de presión política os voy a dar un
ejemplo uno de los mayores aliados
históricos de eeuu es marruecos porque
porque se llaman también pues tienen sus
razones creemos las explicamos en otro
vídeo pero ahora mismo quedaos con qué
marruecos y estados unidos son aliados
desde el siglo 18 en los años 70 como
sabéis marruecos invadió el sáhara que
era una colonia española y españa quiso
defenderlo con sus tanques que o
sorpresa estaba
en estados unidos así que washington
llegó a madrid y dijo en español
mira como te ve usando mis tanques para
atacar a mi colega aquí mohamed el
marroquí es que me voy a en la ex
paquita no te vayas todavía paquito ven
aquí que tengo que seguir leyendo la
cartilla tu sabes quién te vende las
ruedas los tornillos y los repuestos de
este tanque de los vende papi así que
como vi a uno de estos tanques dando
vueltas por ahí por el sáhara sabes te
va a vender repuestos se va a vender
repuestos tu madre
paquito tu padre hala ya te puedes ir
para casa a comer tortilla con alioli y
sin pensaba es que eso de la presión
política sólo funciona con dictaduras
como se equivocase mirad lo que les pasa
ahora a los noruegos
los f-35 envían datos sensibles del
ejército noruego a lockheed martin en
eeuu como os quedáis
cuando hablamos de armamento todo esto
del libre mercado la globalidad tirado
ni tal se va un poco como a freír
churros y como os podéis imaginar dentro
de eeuu hay una enorme presión para no
dejar de gastar nunca en armas
pensándolo bien hablamos de un millón y
medio de personas que viven de la
industria militar por ejemplo cuando
hablamos de sf 35 no sólo se trata de
mucho dinero para lockheed martin
también hablamos de miles de empleos y
eso mis queridos amigos de visual
política es un arma de seducción masiva
porque lo que más le gusta a un
congresista de texas es llegar a sus
votantes y decir chavales que acabo de
conseguir que la nueva fábrica del f-35
esté en texas ale de nada en otras
palabras que el lobby militar en eeuu
tiene una fuerza enorme no sólo hablamos
de geopolítica sino también de políticas
de empleo y eso explica que aquel
discurso de eisenhower siga siendo de
rabiosa actualidad
en los consejos de gobierno tenemos que
protegernos de la influencia buscada o
no buscada de la industria militar
industrial convex
porque el potencial desastroso de tanto
poder fuera de lugar existe y existirá
así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros os parece que eeuu gasta
demasiado en defensa o es importante
mantenerse a la cabeza de la tecnología
militar
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y si queréis estar al día de
lo que ocurre en el mundo de las fuerzas
armadas ahí tenéis mi canal en youtube
cosas militares o escribo habitualmente
para el medio política el rol de muchas
gracias y ha sido un placer y como
siempre no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros a visual política y darle a
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo darle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]